wat heel veel mensen denk ik niet zien
zeker niet in de politiek
is dat dit soort dingen ook averechts werken
dus dat het zo moeilijk is om 1 huurder eruit te zetten
gaan heel veel mensen hun pand niet te huur aanbieden
en dus verpest je eigenlijk de huurmarkt
hetzelfde met werknemers
omdat je bijna niet meer van iemand kan afkomen
als je hem eenmaal
hebt aangeboden
gaan heel veel mensen niet meer mensen aannemen
dus uiteindelijk bijt je in je eigen staart
als overheid je wilt het goed regelen
maar het tegenovergestelde gebeurt precies
als het dan omhoog gaat
dan neem je eigenlijk te weinig mensen aan
omdat je ze moeilijk weer kan ontslaan
als het naar beneden gaat HEB je veel te veel energie
en dan val je om
omdat je veel te veel salariskosten hebt
dus dat is totaal niet handig